So the first thing that we want to do is remove all of these artistic effects.
We also want to clamp our exposure compensation.
So to do that, we're going to do that through a post-processing volume.
So I'll jump back over to the engine real fast.
And again, I'll go to unlit mode so we can see what we're working with here.
Go over to your place actors.
The easiest way is just to start typing in post, and we'll grab this post-processing volume.
So we'll drag this into our scene.
I'm going to go down to my transformations and just click the little loop back arrow here to reset our settings.
So if I jump back, you can follow along in these slides for the different settings that we're going to use.
But essentially, we are going to recreate what we see here inside of our scene.
All right. Now, because we don't have any lights, it's going to be rather difficult to kind of see what's happening.
But essentially, our post-processing is going to control a host of different artistic or visual effects into our scene.
And we will see that later exemplified when we actually have some of our lighting.
But for now, we can just follow along with this.
So the first thing that I want to do is with my post-processing volume selected, go over into my details panel.
I'm going to scroll all the way down until I see the post-processing volume settings.
And the first thing that I want to do is check the infinite extent unbound.
Now, there are situations where you may want to localize or control your post-processing effects within just that volume or that shape.
And that is the default nature and behavior of our post-processing volumes.
However, for this, we don't want it to we don't want those effects to be contained just to the post-processing volume shape.
We want them to continue to propagate no matter where the camera is positioned.
And that's what infinite extent unbound is going to do.
All right. So with that checked and we have enabled, we're going to scroll back up.
And the first thing I'm going to look for is my exposure tab.
So if I expand this out, any time that we have a setting and we check the box,
we are now overriding whatever the default behavior or the current setting is based off of priority,
which in this case, as we only have one post-processing volume, we are simply just going to change this setting.
So on our exposure compensation, I'm going to change this to negative five point five.
What does that number come from?
Simply just because of the light values that we're using, the fact that we're trying to adhere to more realistic values.
We'll find this later with our directional light.
A value of negative five point five is going to give us correct or at least visually correct exposure in our scene.
However, note that this particular parameter you can adjust up or down if your scene is too bright or too dark.
That's not the most critical component.
The next component that we actually want to change is our min and max EV.
In fact, this is going to be directly correlated with our exposure compensation.
So if we clamp these both at one and one or zero and zero or whatever the same value is,
this essentially fix the auto exposure.
So now the engine won't try to adjust the exposure of our in-game camera or how we're viewing based off of these numbers.
So those few settings right there should be all that we need to disable our auto exposure
and allow the post processing volume to take effect across the whole scene.
Now, we could go in as well, as you had heard me mention, too, about adjusting some of our artistic effects.
For example, I could take chromatic aberration, check the intensity to make sure it does, in fact, overwrite at zero.
We could change our bloom intensity to zero as well.
Again, anything artistic related, disabling it.
Of course, we can always re-enable these later through a secondary post processing volume,
but simply just check the parameter itself and go ahead and set the value to zero.